that's where the BBC is just trying to
antagonize me now
[Applause]
so on Sunday I put up a video talking
about we had it confirmed that the Jodie
Whittaker was coming back from series 12
but we didn't have come and I mentioned
in that video we didn't have
confirmation about when season series 12
is airing or whether or not chip know
was coming back and that same day that
video went up BBC announces chip knows
back and and series 12 will air in 2020
which means no new series proper for
Doctor Who in 2019 the same day okay so
let's talk about that then so let's
start I mean it makes sense to pair
these announcements together there's no
reason not to and one would presume
Chibnall is gonna be working on scripts
and whatever else all through 2019 now I
am sure that people with a more
conspiratorial bent to their you know
assessments of things than I have will
be coming up with all sorts of things
along the lines of you know that he it's
taking this much time cuz there's gonna
be a major retooling and he's fighting
with the BBC or whatever all of that is
distinctly possible but I also don't
know so I'm not gonna speculate on that
here's what I will say is that the it's
said that the next series is gonna start
in January of 2020 so it's actually not
that far out from where it would have
been if they were airing it around the
same time that they aired the series 11
it's a couple months push back so even
though we're looking at okay it's gonna
be 2027 2019 it's not actually a full
year later than when we were expecting
it it's about two months in two or three
months actually which you know makes it
sound a little bit more reasonable now
the thing that we don't know yet and I'm
not because they haven't announced this
I'm not taking it as a given either way
but we don't know if there will be a
special in 2019 for my
honey I bet there is because that way we
avoid having no new Doctor Who in 2019
and also it would put us in the
situation that we actually have
precedent for because lest we forget
that after series nine with Capaldi the
following year there were no no new
Doctor Who episodes until the Christmas
special that year so what happened was
at after at the end of series 9
Christmas of that year we had husbands
of River Song
it was husband yes it was husbands of
River Song and then the following
Christmas we had the return of doctor
Mysterio and then the year following we
had knew we had series 10 so we'd
actually have precedent for this the
reasons can't possibly be the same
though because part of the reason or at
least my understanding a part of the
reason that happened back then with
Capaldi was because with Moffat show or
any he would the guy was just juggling
too much he was just doing too much
stuff he had to wrap up series four of
Sherlock and he probably had like two or
three up there things going I don't like
the I honestly do think the guy
overworked himself especially at the
tail end of that stretch so I think that
young there was a pretty understandable
reason why in that case we don't have
that at play here now that doesn't mean
that there isn't a perfectly rational
reasonable you know not everybody's
fighting behind the scenes explanation
for why it would happen now but from
context there isn't an obvious answer
the way there was that so that's sort of
my general assessment on the no new
episodes until 2020 I'm a little bit
bummed because I don't like waiting for
Doctor Who but I mean it is what it is
of we've been here before so what can
you do I like I said keep in mind it's
really only a three month delay not a
year delay which you know I I think you
puts it in a little bit better
perspective in terms of Chibnall himself
coming back I think my thoughts on this
will be made
a little bit clearer because I am gonna
have a video coming up this week sort of
giving my overall assessment of series
11 well you know what I'm gonna talk
heck with it I'm gonna talk now about
sort of my thoughts of what I'd like to
see from him in a future series since
this is a video about future series
anyway when I talk series 11 I'll just
talk about how he was in series 11 so
here's here's my main thing he was the
weakest writer on his own show so what
my inclination would be right now here's
the thing I don't I don't think that we
actually should be getting rid of him
necessarily I do think he needs to take
his hands off the actual scripts because
as I said the episodes that I thought
were the best ones
he didn't write and while there were a
couple that he did write that I liked I
didn't love any of the ones that he
liked and that he wrote so that leaves
me in a position where I have to think
he would be better in a supervisory
position over a writers room and not
actually banging out the scripts himself
which does have precedent not in modern
era Doctor Who because it modern era
Doctor Who you know you had Russell T
Davies and then Moffat who both wrote a
lot of scripts in their time but prior
to that you would have show runners who
didn't actually write the scripts
Jonathan Nathan Turner didn't write
scripts Verity Lambert didn't write
scripts there were others as well but I
don't want to name others because I
might get some of them mixed up as to
which ones did or didn't write scripts
or only liberal like one or two but
being the showrunner back certainly
during classic who did not mean that you
were writing a bunch of the scripts it
meant you were supervising the show the
direction of the show offering ideas
situations approving scripts but not
necessarily writing them yourself
and that also can happen
and actually a lot of times in American
television the you there are a heck of a
lot of shows with you know created by or
executive producer credits for people
who are you know guiding hands for the
show but are writing scripts day you
know week over week and I kind of I'm at
the feeling at this point that that
might be the better fit for chip know
because when I think about a lot of the
concepts that went into series 11 I
actually like a lot of them on paper it
was an execution issue and it wasn't an
execution issue of the performances or
the shooting because the show looked
gorgeous and I thought the performances
were pretty much solid across the board
from guests and regulars so when I say
execution I mean the actual scripts from
the the issues seemed to be happening
from concept to to written word and that
is where I feel like Chibnall might be
best off sort of removing himself from
that process or working with a more
heavy-handed co-write or more often
because again like there are there are a
lot of ideas even in the ones that he
scripted himself that for the most part
I like I think the only episode that I
really really disliked was arachnids in
in the UK but pretty much everything
else even if I didn't love the episode I
saw the oh the general overall concepts
that could and should have worked but
something was off a little bit so I like
that's what I would like to see do I
think that's actually gonna happen no
because I think the general perception
especially for British TV right now is
the showrunner is is also the head
scripter I mean that's so much the case
in in British television right now that
there's a there's a bunch of series out
there that literally there's only one
person writing all the scripts for a
show like that's not uncommon in the UK
so I don't know if the culture in the
production end of things exists
at the BBC or a UK TV production general
to allow that to happen which is
unfortunate because that does mean that
he's gonna be writing more scripts I'm
kind of crossing my fingers he's gonna
write a lower percentage of him like
maybe just the premiere in the finale so
like I have not been thrilled with
Chibnall writing but I see enough good
core concepts in his overall approach
that I don't think it's necessary to
jettison him at least not at this point
and I kind of want to see what he does
with feedback and taking another shot I
will get very frustrated if we get to
series 12 and I basically see the same
kind of writing issues that I saw this
time because that's just not accepting
that you could have done better and I
know a lot of the people saying that
there were issues with the series have
not been saying it politely so I would I
wouldn't necessarily blame him for his
inclination to ignore the complaining
fandom cuz a lot of them have been real
jerks about it I mean come on guys you
can dislike something love being a jerk
about it so you know for that reason I
can't necessarily blame him if he just
wants to drown out the criticism but I
would really like to see what he can do
taking it on board and and adapting
because that that to me is the overall
strength of Doctor Who as a show is its
adaptability adaptability in the
characterization of the doctor as a
character because you can change doctor
the adaptability in the scripts through
new writers new directions new all sorts
of things so I would like to see what
Chibnall can do adapting to you know
trying to do something else something
different I don't know if that's what
he'll actually try and I'm not necessary
and I'm not really gonna speculate again
because that sort of starts to dip into
is there drama
behind-the-scenes is you know is he
gonna have total control is it like I
don't want to I don't want to go down
that path but in any case yeah he's
sticking around
new episodes not until 2020 your
thoughts on this whatever they are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it whole bunch stuff you can do
because there's buttons and links
including one to my patreon that'd be
awesome if you want to support me that
way if you don't though it's okay cuz
there's other links to check out as well
I don't want to click on any of them
that's fine too because at the end of
the day you're the council I just run
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]